Welcome back to State of the Union.
The January six
committee is set to release its report
next month,
but some staff say
it may not represent all their findings.
Sources told The Washington Post
that they felt
Republican Congresswoman Liz
Cheney was only interested in evidence
that pertained to former President Trump,
which prompted a fire response
from a spokesperson for Cheney
and also one from the committee.
Here with me now to discuss January six
and a lot of other issues
is a member of that committee,
Democrat Adam Schiff.
Thank you so much for coming in.
Let's start with that Post report,
which was a really remarkable report.
Staffers were told
the final January six report
would likely
almost entirely focus on Donald Trump,
potentially leaving out
a significant amount of your committee's
report and investigation, other areas.
That's what The Post said. Is it true?
No.
I mean, I certainly hope not.
I would like to see our report
be as broad and inclusive as possible.
We are discussing as a committee
among the members
what belongs in the body of the report,
what belongs
in the appendices of the report.
What is beyond
the scope of our investigation?
And we'll reach those decisions
in a collaborative manner.
You know,
I think the one of the things
that has made our committee
so successful is we have worked extremely
well together.
That doesn't mean
we always agree on everything,
but it does mean
we have a lot of respect for each other.
And we get to the
the goal,
which is
providing the American people
with a full accounting of what
took place on January six.
That has certainly been
the public perception of it
and the public face of the committee.
But it sounds like
there's a different story,
at least in some parts of the committee
behind the scenes.
Liz Cheney,
spokesman, put out a statement
accusing staffers on that very committee
on her own
committee of trying to slip,
quote, liberal biases into the report.
Here's what this quote said,
that Cheney
won't sign on to any narrative
that suggests Republicans
are inherently racist
or smears men and women
in law enforcement or suggests
every American who believes
God has blessed
America is a white supremacist.
And then
a committee spokesman
accused disgruntled
staffers of, quote, cowardice and said
they're helping
Donald Trump and others
responsible for the violence
of January six.
That's a remarkable statement.
They are
you know,
I don't think the back and forth
is particularly helpful.
The committee and I don't
want to engage in that.
We're going to get to a
consensus on the report.
We're very close to that now.
We're close to the putting down
the pen and go into print.
And I think the report
is going to set out in a
I hope, very comprehensive way.
What took place, what led to that attack
and and all the circumstances around
that.
We're also going to be
releasing the evidence,
which may be the most important thing,
the voluminous transcripts,
the documents and emails.
We want to make sure that that's
put before the American people.
We certainly don't want the Jim
Jordan's of the world to cherry pick
anything not disclosed
and make a false
or misleading narrative out of it.
So the country is going to have
the evidence
they're going to have our report.
And I'm enormously proud
of what we've done
and we'll be proud of the final result.
Well, I was going to ask you about that.
Jim Jordan has already said that
he is going to
he will be the chairman
of the Judiciary Committee.
He is likely
he is going to go through the evidence
you left out.
You're saying that
there won't be evidence
that will not be made public.
The evidence will all be made public.
Now, we'll have to make sure that
we scrub
that evidence for personally identifiable
information, that the evidence
that we provide protects people's
security.
Does it put them at risk?
So there are things
that we're going to have to do
along those lines.
But but, yes,
we want to put the evidence
before the American people,
which supports
the hearings that we've done,
as well as the report that we'll put out
and will be a comprehensive picture.
A few weeks after January six,
you said the attack on the Capitol
was, quote, a massive intelligence
and security failure
that needs to be fully investigated.
There were nine public hearings.
None had a specific focus on
exactly that, on the security
and intelligence failures.
Will those be detailed
in the final report?
I certainly hope they will,
and I'm advocating for that.
I think that's part of the broad picture
of why
the Capitol was vulnerable to attack.
What intelligence
we had, what intelligence we missed,
what intelligence was put
before law enforcement.
Are you meeting resistance?
I'm getting that in.
You know,
I don't want to go
into our internal discussions
I think we'll get to common agreement.
Part of it is, you know,
what belongs in the body of the report,
what belongs in the separate appendices.
You know, what can be corroborated
We want to make sure that we have
every fact nailed down.
That's been part of the reason
our committee has been so successful.
And we want it to continue to be.
I want to move on.
But before I do,
there does seem to be tension
surrounding the vice chair
of the committee, Liz Cheney.
One former
staffer told The Washington Post
that people working for the committee
became quote, discouraged
when they felt
it had become
a, quote, Cheney 20, 24 campaign affair.
I've never viewed it that way.
And I think her role on
the committee has been indispensable.
I have tremendous respect for her
and for Adam Kinzinger.
They've shown
a lot of courage and backbone
as something in very short supply.
In the GOP these days.
So the committee not would not have been
the same
without both of their participation.
And and I have nothing but respect
for both of them.
As you well know,
the man who was trying to be speaker.
Republican Kevin McCarthy, says that he
wants to kick you off
the Intelligence Committee,
the committee that you now chair
because of your handling of the Trump
Russia investigation, and specifically
that you repeatedly asserted that
there was direct evidence
of collusion and direct collusion
which didn't materialize.
What's your response to McCarthy?
Well, McCarthy
apparently doesn't think it's collusion.
If your campaign manager
is giving inside polling
data and battle strategy in key states
to engage in Russian intelligence
while the Russians
are helping your campaign.
But most Americans
would call that collusion.
McCarthy's problem is not with
what I've said about Russia.
McCarthy's problem is
he can't get to to 18
without Marjorie Taylor Greene
and Paul Gosar and Matt Gaetz.
And so he will do whatever they ask.
And right now,
they're asking for me
to be removed from my committees.
And he's willing to do it.
He's willing to do anything they ask.
And that's the problem.
Kevin McCarthy has no ideology.
He has no core set of beliefs.
It's very hard
only to get to to a team that way.
It's even more difficult to keep to 18.
That's his problem.
So he will misrepresent my record.
He'll misrepresent Eric
Swalwell or Ilhan Omar or whatever
he needs to do
to get the votes of the QAnon caucus
within this conference.
He's not the only one.
The incoming oversight chair.
James Comer told Punchbowl
News in an interview.
I don't believe
congressional investigations
have a whole lot of credibility now.
I blame Adam Schiff for that.
But it's also both parties
to blame for investigations in the past.
I want to change that.
What's your response?
Well, Coburn doesn't believe
in the Russia investigation.
He doesn't believe
in the Ukraine investigation.
He doesn't believe in the investigation.
January 6th and why?
Because those are investigations
of the serial abuse
of power
by Donald Trump and Colmer and Jordan
and McCarthy
will do nothing but carry
Donald Trump's water.
Someone, as you point out,
who is sitting down for dinner
with anti-Semites,
who's sitting down for dinner
with bigots, who won't condemn them.
This is
who they're making common cause with.
And so they will do.
And what
and they will say what they need
to get along with Donald Trump.
We're out of time.
But I just have to ask,
if you are subpoenaed
by Republicans
when they take over where you can play.
You know what?
We'll have to consider
the validity of the subpoena
but I would certainly view my obligation,
the administration's obligation
to follow the law
and the fact that they have disrespected
the law is not a precedent
I would hope
that would be broadly followed.
But we'll have to look at the legitimacy
or lack of legitimacy of what they do.